elles sont partout sur les routes dans
les parkings et même sur les trottoirs
impossible de ne plus les remarquer les
trottinettes électriques se sont
installées en ville les témoignages de
piétons excédés se sont en effet
multipliés ces dernières années sur les
réseaux sociaux dénonçant le danger que
représenterait ce nouveau mode de
transport certains avancent même qu'il
fait plus de victimes que la voiture ou
la moto et qu'il faudrait l'interdire on
a donc décidé dans ce nouvel épisode de
factu de faire un point en chiffres sur
ces allégations les trottinettes
électriques sont-elles réellement
dangereuses
il faut tout d'abord établir ce qui est
vrai la trottinette électrique est à
l'origine de nombreux accidents selon
l'Observatoire National interministériel
de la sécurité routière ils ont même
augmenté significativement ces trois
dernières années en 2019 l'ony sert a en
effet comptabilisé 556 blessés et 10
morts dans des accidents impliquant des
engins de déplacement personnellement
motorisés les ETPM dont font partie les
trottinettes électriques en 2020 il y a
eu 774 blessés et sept morts et en 2021
c'est l'explosion avec 1360 blessés et
24 morts enfin pour 2022 un rapport
provisoire de la sécurité routière datée
du 31 janvier 2023 indique que 34
personnes sont décédées soit une
augmentation de 240% par rapport à 2019
570 personnes ont quant à elle été
blessées gravement dans des accidents
impliquant des edpm il est aussi
important de distinguer les victimes en
2021 sur 1360 blessés 1288 soit 95%
étaient des conducteurs et les 24
victimes mortelles comptabilisés cette
année-là l'étaient également il y a une
de clivage entre celles et ceux qui
souhaitent préserver des un service en
libre-service de trottinette électrique
et celles et ceux qui souhaitent arrêter
et dont je fais d'ailleurs partie donc
l'idée étant d'avoir un débat un débat à
la fois sur les trottinettes électriques
et puis plus globalement sur les
mobilités les micro mobilités et puis la
manière de se déplacer en centre-ville
la situation n'a plus rien à voir avec
celle de 2018-2019 on a une situation
qui est plus régulée par contre on a
encore trop de problèmes on a encore
trop de problèmes en termes de
stationnement de désordre dans l'espace
public et puis il y a un problème aussi
de civisme d'usage et notamment avec des
vitesses excessives et puis le fait
qu'il y a un nombre d'accidents qui
augmentent bref il y a un sujet de
sécurité il y a un sujet d'espace public
et un sujet d'écologie aussi ce sont des
appareils avec une faible durée de vie
tout ça pose le fait que et bien est-ce
qu'on souhaite continuer ou pas avec ses
services qui posent vraiment beaucoup de
difficultés mais alors qu'est-ce qui
explique un tel nombre d'accidents
plusieurs facteurs sont à prendre en
compte le premier c'est l'usage qui en
effet la trottinette électrique est un
mode de transport relativement récent
les premiers chiffres fiables remontent
à 2018 année lors de laquelle plusieurs
multinationales ont inondé le marché
occidental de ces engins motorisés
depuis le secteur s'est développé sans
pour autant arriver à maturité ainsi en
2021 on comptabilisé 2,5 millions
d'utilisateurs réguliers de trottinette
électrique en France et parmi les
usagers de trottinette électrique en
libre-service un tiers serait des
touristes conjugués au fait qu'il
s'agisse d'un moyen de transport récent
le fait que la plupart des utilisateurs
de trottinette en fast en usage très
occasionnel signifie qu'ils sont peu
expérimentés dans son maniement
augmentant ainsi la probabilité
d'accident la maniabilité de ces engins
favorise aussi les comportements à
risque on se croit tout simplement
meilleur conducteur qu'on ne les
réellement une explosion de l'usage des
trottinettes en 2021 il y a eu plus de
trottinettes vendues que de voitures
vendues et donc l'usage a été multiplié
par 6 ou 7 dernières années seulement
20% des usagers de trottinette s'assure
au moins et ceux qui s'assurent sont les
plus prudents et donc c'est ceux qui
vont plutôt mettre des casques et qui
font l'effort de s'assurer et que nous
ce qu'on remarque c'est qu'il y a
finalement très peu d'accidentologie sur
la population des trottinettes assurées
enfin l'adoption massive de ce nouveau
moyen de transport n'a pas été anticipé
par les agglomérations les voiries n'ont
pas eu le temps d'être adaptées à ces
moyens de transport capables de circuler
sur route voici club mais également sur
les trottoirs un grand nombre
d'utilisateurs encore inexpérimenté et
un milieu urbain mal adapté c'est la
recette parfaite pour créer des
accidents on a aujourd'hui une sorte de
de mythe qui s'est installée et qui
pensent que dans une ville comme Paris
qui est une toute petite ville très
dense et bien on peut utiliser un peu
comme on veut des engins de déplacement
or ce n'est pas possible pendant deux
ans deux ans et demi nous avons fait la
course avec les opérateurs sur les
questions de régulation en pratique
malgré tout ce qu'on nous vous explique
et tout ce que nous disent aujourd'hui
les opérateurs nous avons les plus
grandes difficultés à faire respecter la
régulation l'usage et pas du tout le
même que lorsque vous avez des
trottinettes à vous par exemple si vous
avez une trottinette et que vous vous en
servez pour aller à votre lieu de
travail et puis enfin sur la question de
la comparaison avec les Vélib' bien sûr
qu'il y a des éléments qui sont communs
mais il y a aussi une grande différence
c'est que le vélo en fait ne
s'appréhende pas de la même manière que
les trottinettes dans l'espace public
pour une raison simple c'est que l'usage
du vélo aujourd'hui et porter une
certaine manière par des infrastructures
qui lui sont dédiées vous avez des
pistes cyclables vous avez des arceaux
vélo vous avez des lieux en fait pour
vous stationner que globalement l'usage
du vélo c'est que ça pose encore plein
de problèmes de civisme etc est en train
de rentrer progressivement dans les
mœurs et qu'une sorte de Culture Vélo
est en train de de se construire
aujourd'hui dans une dans une ville
comme comme Paris on n'a pas du tout les
mêmes appréhensions avec les
trottinettes
sont des éléments qui sont des éléments
extrêmement importants qui font que nous
n'appréhendons pas ou que nous pensons
pas tout à fait l'usage du vélo de la
même manière que par exemple
les trottinettes électriques en
libre-service par contre il y a des
comportements anormaux un peu comme dans
tous les usages qui ont lieu si on
regarde au début du Vélib' à Paris on
avait exactement ces questions sur
est-ce qu'il faut les interdire les
Vélib' se comportent n'importe comment
et finalement ça c'est totalement
normalisé et donc premièrement il faut
un peu plus de règles un peu les faire
un peu plus respectés y compris sur la
trottinette je pense que c'est plus un
sujet réglementation et éventuellement
de la faire respecter que que un sujet
de formation donc je pense qui est
important c'est de remettre beaucoup de
faits et de Data dans le débat pour que
on sorte des postures pour autant la
trottinette électrique est-elle
réellement dangereuse si dans l'absolu
les chiffres des accidents parlent
d'eux-mêmes il faut cependant les
relativiser si on les compare à des
autres moyens de transport on peut
établir la proportion des accidents
impliquant les trottinettes électriques
en se basant sur les chiffres des
grandes métropoles comme Paris dans une
étude datée de 2020 la répartition des
usagers impliqués dans des accidents de
la circulation indiquent très clairement
que la trottinette électrique est loin
d'être le moyen de transport le plus
dangereux elle ne représente que 4,3% de
l'ensemble c'est 3 fois moins que les
vélos 6 fois moins que les motos et 9
fois moins que les voitures on pourrait
arguer qu'il y a moins d'utilisateurs de
trottinette que de moto de vélo ou
d'auto ce qui fausserait les chiffres en
un moindrissant la part de ses engins
dans les accidents corporels une étude
californienne c'est justement penchée
sur la question en utilisant une
intelligence artificielle capable
d'analyser 36 millions de dossiers
médicaux des chercheurs ont réussi à
obtenir des chiffres fiables ils se sont
basés non pas sur le nombre
d'utilisateurs mais plutôt le nombre de
trajets et les résultats sont édifiants
ils ont pu trouver que la trottinette
électrique est bien plus dangereuse que
ce que de précédentes études ont pu
déterminer elle apparaît comme le moyen
de transport qui blesse le plus avec
près de 115 blessés par millions de
trajets dépassant ainsi la moto avec 104
blessés et amplement le vélo avec 15
blessés quand la voiture en fait que 8
pour ce qui est des accidents mortels la
trottinette et cependant loin d'être le
moyen de transport le plus meurtrier
pour 100 millions de trajet 19 personnes
meurent en trottinette qu'en 537 perdent
la vie à moto les vélos eux
comptabilisent 21 tués